Football was footballing last week and I
think we were reminded that it's a
dangerous sport and these young men are
putting their themselves on the line and
there is a risk of injury kind of like
when kind of like race car drivers you
know
it doesn't happen all the time but there
is risk there could be a terrible
accident it's the same thing with these
super athletic strong powerful men are
slamming into each other every week on
occasion something like this can happen
and it was on such a public stage I mean
I actually really appreciated how for
the most part we were kind of like as a
as a nation just kind of like if
football fans were like oh man I hope
this dude's okay and I know this is just
a game and we were kind of like
supporting him and people were
supporting his toy drive and just
supporting him and a lot of people were
coming out and talking about it and then
there were parents out there would you
let your kids play football like did it
change your mind after you saw what
happened to this guy